wir sind jetzt übrigens schon so weit
gekommen dass irgendwelche zwölfjährigen
sechsklässler ihre Lehrer öffentlich bei
tiktok bewerten und das sogar komplett
Ernst hier wird zum Beispiel Herr Wale
bewertet und natürlich wird das Gesicht
nicht zensiert ging auch bisschen viral
bisschen komisch kann korrekt sein und
jetzt weiß natürlich auch jeder dass er
seit 5 Jahren auf Frau Reichert steht
also sorry ich habe vor paar Jahren Abi
gemacht aber da wäre sowas undenkbar
gewesen die Lehrer die hat mich
Frau Kösters wird auch bewertet als sehr
korrekt und nett und die schreibt sogar
einen Kommentar danke hätte ich damals
meine Lehrer öffentlich und Ernst in dem
Youtube Video bewertet wäre ich Safe von
der Schule geflogen und heute ist das
irgendwie normal